et là les billets au coeur de tensions
entre washington et moscou ce mardi le
commandant en chef des forces armées
américaines en afrique accuse bien aussi
d'avoir déployé des avions de chasse
pour soutenir des mercenaires présent au
sol ces derniers combattent aux côtés du
maréchal khalifa haftar opposants au
gouvernement de tripoli
reconnu par l'onu ces accusations ont
été démenties par moscou qui les
qualifie de fausses nouvelles
inventé par washington et pour en parler
nous retrouvons notre correspondant
antoine gayraud en direct de moscou
bonjour antoine merci à d'être avec moi
alors en quoi consistent ces accusations
exactement et quelle a été la réaction
de moscou
et bien tout commence avec la
publication d'un communiqué du
commandement des états unis pour
l'afrique avec prudence le document
estime que des avions de combat russes
ont été récemment déployé en libye et
fournirait un soutien aérien à des
sociétés militaires privées sur le
terrain les avions en question serait
arrivé depuis la russie via la base
aérienne russe située en syrie où il
aurait été repeint pour masquer leur
origine les responsables militaires qui
ont ensuite commenté ce communiqué de
presse ne se sont pas embarrassés de
l'emploi du conditionnel un ch'ti un
porte parole du pentagone affirme sans
ambages que les russes ont envoyé 14
avions militaires en libye une
accusation que réfute donc moscou le
vice président de la commission à la
défense de la douma andré crasse of a
répondu que cette information je cite ne
correspondaient pas à la réalité il au
passage rappelé la position de la russie
sur ce dossier comme quoi moscou appelle
à la fin des effusions de sang en libye
et exhorte toutes les parties au conflit
à ne pas avoir recours aux armes et à
s'asseoir à la table des négociations
antoine gayraud à merci et vocaux pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous étiez en direct de moscou versée